MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to special relativity.
Bending of light is one of
the spectacular consequences
of general relativity, a
prediction, if you want,
[? of ?] [? general ?]
relativity,
which was experimentally
confirmed.
But let's analyze
the situation first
before we look at
the actual evidence.
They use Alice and
Bob again, where
Alice is an elevator operator.
She's stationary and
operating this elevator.
Bob is a passenger and
riding within the elevator.
So Alice is injecting
a light beam
and watching this light beam
in the elevator from outside.
And the light beam,
as you would expect,
is going in a straight line.
We'll see pictures here show
the elevator at three different
times-- [? t1, ?]
[? t2, ?] and t3.
For Bob, the very same situation
looks completely different.
He sees the light
entering the elevator.
And then after some
time, the light pulse
is maybe on the
height of his head.
And after some additional time,
he sees the light at the end--
or at the bottom
part of the elevator.
So if you would draw a line
on the back of the elevator
where he was able to
observe the light pulses,
you could draw this line.
So for Bob, who's stationary
in this accelerating reference
frame, light is bending.
As we discussed in the first
section in this chapter,
there's an equivalence
between accelerating
and the gravitational field
causing an acceleration.
And so you can use heavy
objects, like the Sun,
in order to bend light.
And this led to the
first observation
of the rotational
bending of light.
And so in order to
do this, we want
to have a star very
close, or starlight
passing very close to the Sun.
And because the Sun is very
bright, you want to use solar--
a total solar eclipse in
order to test this effect.
And this was first
achieved in 1919
with a solar eclipse
in Brazil, also
at the West Coast of
Africa, by Arthur Eddington.
And so this then led to
Einstein really becoming famous.
I talk about this later.
You might remember the
last partial eclipse here
in Massachusetts in 2017.
I have a vivid memory of
this, showing this to my kids
up into the sky, obviously,
with proper eye protection.
So the idea is, again,
that you have a star,
and light passes by the Sun.
And because of the gravitational
bending of the Sun,
there's a bending effect.
So there seems to be an
offset of the actual start
position due to the bending.
And this effect,
again, was discovered--
or was measured in 1919 by
Arthur Eddington, and let's--
maybe because of an article
in The New York Times
to the fame of Albert Einstein.
So at the time, there
was no science reporters
for newspapers.
So a former sports
reporter reported
on the scientific endeavor.
And the way he writes about
it is rather interesting.
You might want to read
the entire article.
But here's just the headlines.
And it read like, "Lights All
Askew in the Heavens," "Men
of Science More or
Less Agog Over Results
Of Eclipse Observations,"
"Einstein's
Theory Trumphs," Stars not Where
They Seemed or Were Calculated
to Be, But Nobody Need to
Worry," "A Book for 12 Wise
Men," "No more in all the
world could comprehend it,"
said Einstein, when his
daring publisher accepted it.
So, again, this populous writing
made Einstein very popular.
He was then later
invited to come and visit
to the United States and
made a tour, which he also
used for political reasons.
But, really, it made
him very, very famous--
made him a pop star of the time.